no
el atletismo en kenia se vistió de luto
miles de personas asistieron al funeral
de acné siave tiró la atleta keniata
quien tuvo una muerte violenta el pasado
jueves 13 de octubre a los 25 años de
edad en la ceremonia realizada en el
condado de nandi los asistentes le
dedicaron un minuto de silencio y una
canción
joaquín es una potencia para nosotros en
kenia hemos perdido una heroína que ha
estado luchando por nuestro país ya
sabes que cuando corremos en muchos
campeonatos es como ir a la guerra
porque no es una tarea fácil correr y
dar fama a nuestro país que ni el que
ibrahimovic esposo y principal
sospechoso del asesinato confesó haber
acabado con la vida de la atleta en una
carta que dejó en la casa donde ambos
vivían explicando que su relación estaba
llena de peleas después de ser detenido
por la policía cuando intentaba huir del
país y brian compareció ante el tribunal
en donde permanecerá detenido hasta la
próxima audiencia el 20 de noviembre
mientras continúa la investigación tiro
que estableció el 12 de septiembre un
récord mundial en una carrera de 10
kilómetros además de haberse proclamado
como la vencedora de la prueba femenina
del cross de itálica en 2018
convirtiéndose en un referente del
deporte le dije que en 2022 debía ir a
defender mis títulos y representar bien
a nuestro país en los campeonatos del
mundo porque soy la campeona del mundo
le dije que ahora que me voy ella debía
seguir mis pasos
pese a haber ganado dos medallas de
bronce en los 10 metros en los mundiales
de atletismo 2017 y 2019 tiro bound
tenía pendiente conseguir una medalla
olímpica